hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und ich bin zurück mit meinem tagebuch
oh yeah baby dieses video teil 2 ist von
meinem traum diary format müsst ihr
erstmal teil eins sehen falls es noch
nicht getan habt für alle andern viel
spaß wer sich nicht mehr ganz erinnern
kann das letzte mal hat es damit
aufgehört dass ich mich entscheiden
musste ob ich mit martin zusammen sein
möchte oder nicht
es war der 23 zwölfter einen tag vor
weihnachten jetzt haben wir den 24
2005 ein monat mich geschrieben wenn es
seid ihr alle bereit also falls sie noch
etwas zu trinken braucht es jetzt
popcorn oder so denn es wird spannend
die tut mir leid dass ich so lange nicht
geschrieben haben
aber ich habe dich nicht gefunden ich
war gar nicht faul
ich habe mich gefunden ich bin nicht
mehr in marvin das nicht es sogar
unterstrichen ich bin wie in andré aus
der stunde rausgeflogen alter was das
für wendungen sind das denn hier und
wegen marvin stehe ich richtig auf an
der tafel die beiden nerven so doll bei
hab dich lieb niemals mit dem junge
schluss machen dann siehst du kommst an
die tafel weise weise worte fürs leben
okay von 20 der erst einen tag geht es
wieder los hier
es geht los sophie ist jetzt mit andré
zusammen beiden passen doch gar nicht
zueinander
wo ist denn die daniel ist voll nett ich
glaube wir werden mal gute freunde
hier ist daniel ich hätte daniel meiner
klasse nicht so guter erinnerung an ihn
und jetzt steht hier das die beste
freundin mit ihm werde ich darf gar
nicht mehr mit sophie spielen vielleicht
ist marvin doch noch in mir jetzt muss
ich aber ins bett es ist schon 22 uhr 15
bei vanessa hd gdl alter mann ist ich
darf nicht mehr so viel spielen jetzt
bin ich vielleicht doch noch einmal wenn
ich hab mein garten sachs überließ hat
sich gesagt hat dass andere und so nicht
zueinanderpassen hab ich gesagt ich bin
doch in marvin gaye vanessa entscheid
ich mal okay sechsundzwanzigster erster
2000 und halli hallo hallo ich bin froh
dass ich mich mit zu viel gut verstehe
ich weiß selber dass ich jenny viel zu
sehr vernachlässige ich weiß gar nicht
was man denkt ich finde es nicht schlimm
dass sophie und andré zusammen sind
sophie ist jetzt mit andré zusammen die
beiden passen doch gar nicht zueinander
das ist gut dass ich das weiß denn nur
drei menschen bis nur das was das ist
gut dass ich das weiß
wenn du drei menschen wissen dass 27
erster 2005 hatten heute haben wir ein
biotest geschrieben
es hat heute geschneit am ende der
schule habe ich mit ann-christin
gespielt ich weiß nicht ist marvin noch
in mich heute gehe ich schon wieder so
spät ins bett morgen gibt es zeugnisse
gute nacht deines oma meine eltern nicht
so lange wach sein lassen oder 2015 mit
11 12 13 spiel also hier normale appelle
an eltern die weiße 29.10.10 für carlo
teddy es tut mir leid dass ich nicht
geschrieben habe aber ich habe bei
jennifer geschlafen denn ich sehe
plötzlich jennifer ich kriege immer mehr
pickel das nervig und jenny haben zettel
aufgehängt wo steht dass wir mit hunden
gassi gehen vielleicht wird das ja was
draus jetzt wo ich mit marvin zusammen
sein will ist er nicht mehr in mich
diese lovestory ist wirklich die
schlimmste die ich jemals gelesen habe
und der autor ist auch nicht so
talentiert muss ich sagen spannungsbogen
ist jetzt nicht so ich muss dir noch was
sagen andré und sophie haben sich
getrennt also andré hat sich von sophie
getrennt ich finde das so scheiße von
andrea obwohl sie nicht zusammenpassen
die beiden passen dich zusammen aber
trotzdem schweiz
das ist so peinlich sowieso eine sachen
geschrieben ernste aber sie waren nur
eine woche zusammen
leute ihr werdet es nicht glaubt ja ein
liter bestellt und krieg 0 33 dies ist
eine bürger pause weitergeht so aber sie
waren nur eine woche zusammen jetzt habe
ich angst wenn ich und martin zusammen
bin dann dass das vielleicht auch nur so
kurz ist später wird meine unterschrift
so aussehen
ich habe das vw zeichen gemalt weil
marvins nachname mit wie anfängt und
männer mit bauch und wenn ich dann
vanessa höhepunkt und vw cool oder ok
ich brauche ein cliffhanger spielberger
ist 30 der erst 2005 heidi mir war den
ganzen tag so was von langweilig und als
ich im internet war
von jenny auch da sie hat nie zurück
geschrieben ich hab dann geschrieben
okay wenn du mich ignoriert dann werde
ich dich in der schule auch ignorieren
ich will unbedingt als klassensprecher
gewählt werden
falls wir wählen weil deine vanni ich
habe mich verhalten wie so eine
eintagsfliege die so ging die scheibe
fliegt und plötzlich umfiel was denn los
bei mir so ewig floriert mich ich hoffe
ich will klassensprecher in einem satz
weiter zweiter 2005 hallodri ich habe
heute in mathe eine strafarbeit bekommt
weiß gar nicht ob ich in marvin bin
morgen haben wir zur zweiten stunde
juli soll mal sehen seine andré soll mal
seine verlogene fresse halten
er war doch derjenige der nach einer
woche schluss mit so viel gemacht hat
ich will jetzt schlafen gehen gute
nachricht zweiter 2005 ein auf und ab
mit uns
ich bin heute nicht in der schule
gewesen weil ich krank bin mir geht es
schon besser aber trotzdem gehe ich
morgen nicht zur schule
ich habe heute also eben ein zäpfchen
bekommen
ich will sagen das ist nicht wehtun muss
daran denken weil wir waren auf dem
festival und irgendwann nachts kam so
das thema sind zäpfchen dass es so eine
erfindung von irgendwelchen wechseln ist
die einfach nur kinder quälen wollen
über menschen quälen volt und kelly und
ich haben uns kaputtgelacht wegen z4
kelly wenn du das hier siehst zäpfchen
4242 2005 hatte die heute war ich schon
wieder nicht in der schule
dafür hat mir heute ann-christin meine
hausaufgaben erklärt sie ist sogar zu
mir gefahren
ein kristall allerbeste freundin weißt
du du bist nicht diesem drama drin an
christina immer so meine freundin die
normal war
sie ist schon was ganz besonderes
ich habe schon fast alle hausaufgaben
gemacht in templin im hintern
sophie und ein paar andere haben gesagt
dass die schule ohne mich langweilig ist
halt die heute haben wir die sitzordnung
geändert ich muss leider neben marvin
sitzen aber das ist gut weil wir diese
woche nur drei tage haben ich will zu
fasching gar nicht als eisprinzessin
gehen ich will ein mann sein ich hab
dich lieb mein bärchen kuss bei bei
vanessa das ist auch mein bruder
cliffhanger werde ich eine eisprinzessin
oder ein mann zu fasching sein
wer wollte mich zwingender als
prinzessin zu sein ist gar nicht möchte
schaltet auch beim nächsten tagebuch
wieder ein wenn zeiss vanessas leben ist
ein einziges chaos
und das nicht mal bevor sie ihre periode
gekriegt hat tschüss bis dann